in the left's really insane power grab
far-reaching far-fetched bizarre attempt
to just get Donald Trump the latest
Witch Hunt the latest hoax a New York
City judge is now Moonlighting it
appears as an expert in Florida real
estate valuations because Manhattan
Superior Court Justice author and Goran
is his name ruled that former president
Trump committed financial fraud by
inflating the value of his properties to
get better loans and and better
insurance rates really okay among
several absolutely insane and egregious
examples was the judge's valuation of
Mar-A-Lago he said oh is you know as low
as 18 million dollars now for most
people the real estate prices I'm about
to show you just for reference they're
frankly insane however this is what real
estate in Palm Beach Florida especially
with a mass migration out of New York
California New Jersey and and in
Illinois you know happened to cause and
if you own a big mansion in Palm Beach
Florida Oceanfront intercoastal front
these Florida homes these Florida lots
are enormously expensive let me give you
a quick example all right a two acre now
mar-a-lago's 20 acres we'll give you the
details on that in a minute but a two
acre vacant lot only minutes from
Mar-A-Lago it's now currently listed for
a very low 150 million dollars another
150 million dollars for two acres of
dirt with no house on a waterfront lot
another two acre plot of land nearby
Waterfront again the lot the dirt 200
million dollars again no house on it
Mar-A-Lago is an iconic 60 000 square
foot Zone residential also Historic
Landmark mansion and it has a club
legally associated with with it it has a
whopping 58 bedrooms 33 bathrooms it's
located on 20 acres of prime Palm Beach
real estate with a really unique
position why because it has both the
Intercoastal Waterway and Oceanfront
beach now ocean front uh homes uh
literally are a fraction of the size of
Mar-A-Lago without access to the
intercoastal waterways are currently
selling anywhere between 100 150 million
some cases 200 million Rush Limbaugh he
had bought a place for on the beach for
about 4 million a number of years ago
since he passed away it recently sold
for nearly 160 million dollars two more
mansions in Palm Beach significantly
smaller than Mar-A-Lago sold for over
150 million dollars each again you're
talking about one and two acre lots
maybe nice homes that's a pretty
expensive nice home now this year alone
one Mansion a third of the size of our
with a tenth of the land
170 million another considered a tear
down meaning you're going to go in and
you got to rip it all down that was
purchased for a whopping 155 million I
spoke to a number of real estate experts
people in Palm Beach
most said Mar-A-Lago minimum asking
price 500 million if you want to sell it
really fast and many said likely much
more maybe going even as high as one
billion dollars Palm Beach is one of the
most expensive real estate markets in
the entire world there are dozens and
dozens of billionaires that live in in
Palm Beach Florida keep this in mind the
club at Mar-A-Lago generates tens of
millions of dollars in Revenue every
year membership fees starting at two
hundred thousand dollars and by all
serious accounts Mar-A-Lago it might be
one of the most valuable properties in
the entire world certainly one of the
best deals any real estate investor ever
made Donald Trump paid 10 million
dollars for the property but a judge in
New York City with absolutely no
knowledge no experience in real estate
no knowledge no experience in Palm Beach
he thinks he knows better in reality the
judge is guilty of the very thing that
he is accusing Donald Trump of and that
is he based his entire ruling on false
phony fake news fake information and
today the registered Democrat was seen
in court oh he sees the camera once he
notices the camera he starts smiling
over and hi see uh hello everybody it's
me oh it's so good to be on TV this is
not a game what they're trying to do to
Donald Trump and his family meanwhile
New York attorney general Leticia James
who brought this civil case was also in
court seemingly to be eyeballing Donald
Trump obsessively glaring at the former
president and Attorney General James a
2016 election denier ran for office on a
simple message instead of promising to
lock up the many many violent criminals
and investigate real crimes in the state
of New York she vowed to go after she
made a campaign pledge to go after one
man one family and one organization
Donald Trump the Trump family the Trump
organization take a look
I will never be afraid to challenge this
illegitimate president when our
fundamental rights are at stake I
believe that the president of these
United States can be indicted for
criminal offenses
I know my name personally that man in
the White House
[Music]
threatening our fundamental rights yes
we need to focus on Donald Trump and his
abuses we need to follow his money
we need to find out where he's laundered
money we need to find out whether or not
he's engaged in conspiracy it's
important that everyone understand that
the days of Donald Trump are coming to
an end I look forward to going into the
office of Attorney General every day
suing him defending your rights and then
going home
the United States our justice system is
supposed to investigate crimes not
Target people those days seem to be long
gone that is a travesty for this country
you might as well take the Constitution
and shred it if we don't have equal
justice and application of our laws
Donald Trump has been targeted in a
series of cases starting with the
trump-russia hoax that we debunked here
on this show and everybody else in the
media mob was lying about and peddling
conspiracy theories about and by the way
you got all these you know four
indictments state federal level all
perfectly timed amazing they could have
done it much earlier but no let's bring
it up in the middle of an election
season and let's take put them on trial
in 2024 and frankly interfere and
disrupt the presidential election now
this has never ever ever not once in
history ever happen to this country that
a former president has been indicted
once never mind four times the civil
case is especially egregious flimsy
allegations going back years and years
and yet oh let's bring it up just before
the election in fact today according to
Trump the judge dismissed all
allegations prior to 2014 why because
the statute of limitation concerns
whether you hate Donald Trump or you
like Donald Trump it doesn't matter this
is not equal justice this is not lady
just as being blind this is a this is a
that of a Banana Republic now how would
you feel if a prosecutor started combing
through every aspect of your life in
search of a crime and then dragging your
children into it simply because they
don't like you they don't like your
politics and all the while these very
same prosecutors don't do nothing with
all the mountains of evidence that we
now have accumulated on Joe Biden Hunter
Biden all the tens of millions of
dollars at the Biden family made how did
Hunter what did Hunter do when he had no
experience in energy oil gas coal or
Ukraine or or any experience with China
did a lot of energy deals with barisma
in Ukraine and cefc in China and access
to the federal government that pops gave
them and then brags about sharing money
with pops half his income as a matter of
fact they can't even be bothered to
investigate Hunter's drug and
prostitution crimes we've got videotape
likely Pharaoh violations serious now
charges against your President Joe Biden
the bribery money laundering Scandal
allegations and more and more evidence
is appearing every day what if the
grandchildren and nine Biden family
members do for tens of millions of
dollars what expertise do they offer
these foreign countries some of our top
geopolitical foes but if you're Eric
Trump if your name's Donald Trump Jr and
a judge in New York with no real estate
experience thinks your property in
Florida that he's never been to is
overvalued dude uh well you better
buckle up prepare to spend a small
fortune tens and hundreds of millions of
dollars in legal fees to defend yourself
have all control of your properties
taken from you canceled from you you are
canceled as a family from ever doing
business in New York again and then just
for good measure a 250 million dollar
fine based on a prosecutor who ran on a
platform to destroy one man one family
one organization and by the way values
of property worth hundreds and hundreds
of millions of dollars at oh 18 million
Merrick garland does this seem like
justice to you does this seem like equal
application of our laws to you equal
justice under the law because to any
honest person in this country this looks
like what it is political targeting
abusing our justice system and doing it
to impact a presidential election this
is the thing that happens in banana
republics and sadly we know that Merrick
Garland is not an honest individual and
his boss Joe Biden is one of the worst
Liars frankly in the history of the
country hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else